so the guy i'm gonna talk about today
his name is brad jacobs bradley jacobs i
think he goes by but uh we're gonna call
brad jacobs
and this person is super interesting
because they have started
uh five companies that have either gone
public
or are worth over a billion dollars he
started age 23
he's 64 now uh google them brad jacobs
he's worth somewhere in the range of
three four five billion dollars
and he's bought or in both he doesn't
like invest passively like a venture
check
they buy companies and he's bought
something like
six 700 companies and he's done it
across a variety of industries and he's
done the same strategy
over and over and over again in
different industries and it's incredibly
interesting and this guy
uh is very fascinating to me for a
variety of reasons that i'm going to
explain
but andrew have you heard of this guy
brad jacobs do you know anything about
this ever i don't know anything
that's kind of why he's cool he's kind
of on the under the radar if you google
him he's uh
he's got like a bald head and he looks
like a finance guy
because he wears a tie and he's like
pretty um
well spoken and you think that he's just
like a private equity person and i guess
maybe he is
but he's really an entrepreneur he's
very entrepreneurial and he's uh
far more interesting than just a lot of
the typical new york
hedge funny type of folks and so i'm
gonna give you a quick story about his
background
so he's started five things that have
been
quite meaningfully sized so the first
was uh it was called amorex
oil associates he started it when he was
and it was an oil biz it was basically
like an oil brokerage firm
which uh i'm not entirely sure what that
entails
but i imagine it just means uh
connecting
folks who created the oil to large
businesses who are buying the oil
and within a very short amount of time
only about four years
uh remember he started this when he was
23 so by the age of 27 amorex his oil
business was doing 4.7 billion dollars
in gross uh gross oil bookings meaning
he would that's how much oil they're
buying and
uh and selling now i imagine his company
kept a tiny percent of that like one or
two or three percent
but incredibly impressive for a young
guy um and after a few years he sells
that business for a billion dollars
then only a couple months after that he
starts this thing called
hamilton resource uh hamilton resource
he starts
out of uh uh england he convinces a
french bank to give him a billion
dollars
line of credit which he was quite
successful already even though he was
crazy young but uh he made it happen and
he went and secured a line of credit
and here's what he said he goes we moved
physical cargos of oil from one place to
another
the 80s turned out to be a great time in
the oil business and i built hamilton up
to about a billion dollars in revenues
and did business in dozens of countries
uh dozens of countries before i moved
back to the states in 1989.
so between 83 and 89 he started this
business
and it also was huge i believe he ended
up selling it for
a billion dollar north of a billion
dollars so that's business number two
business number three a little bit of a
of an odd one was waste management
um i don't think there's anyone out
there doing waste management stuff now
that's brand new but there's a ton of
companies that
at the time started in the 70s 80s and
90s like waste management the company
waste management
and what they did was they would go out
and find tons of mom and pop
waste management companies because back
then that's how it was it probably is a
little bit to this day
but he started this thing called united
waste management which eventually
became the fifth largest solid waste
business in america
and it had a very very very simple
business plan which was
buy landfills and small markets by many
of the local trucking companies that
were serving those markets
optimize the truck routes maximize the
pricings get margins up
achieve size so that they had the
capability to scale
and they did that and the strategy
worked really well and in just
five years our earnings compounded
annually
annually by 55 percent and the and he
took the company public
something like eight months after
starting it and the stock price went up
as well
50 every single year for like five years
eventually
that company grew to 3.9 billion dollars
in revenue and 1.2 billion dollars in
ebitda
with 750 locations and 13 000 employees
is this freaking crazy oh sorry that i
just gave you the numbers
i gave you the numbers for um his next
business but the waste management grew
to 2.5 billion dollars in revenue
oh sorry uh 2.5 billion dollars and an
exit to waste management
nuts right that's crazy so i i one of
the most interesting things about this
is like
there i always think there's like um
four different types of entrepreneurs
right there's the innovators so
let's just take let's take um chipotle
as an example right so there's the
innovator there's the guy who rolled the
first burrito
and was like oh [__] this tastes really
good um then there's the remixer there's
the person who creates chipotle they
take the burrito they package it up they
create a brand around it
then there's the scalers the person who
scales chipotle to 100 locations
and then there's the optimizer the
person who just sits on top makes sure
it doesn't blow up
and gets as much as possible gets as
much juice out of the lemon
as they can and this guy's a great
example of a scaler
someone who just takes something that
already works that's already proven
and just does a much better job of it
and rolls it out makes it scalable
and builds something massive and it's
super it's super interesting
because i'd say i i kind of fall into
this camp at the same time i feel like
what's sexy about this guy is actually
how boring the businesses are
right they're they're so basic these are
things that are like undisruptible and
when you build them it's like a hundred
year business or something which i think
is really cool
whereas what we do is like five you got
to think in five year
uh chunks i completely agree and if you
scroll up to this document that we have
open and you click source
um the source that i'm using for a lot
of this and this is so
interesting um so we're on business
number three i'll get to four and five
in a second
but when what this guy does and then
when i wrap up all five i'll explain to
you
what my lessons uh learn from this guy
are but i'll say one of them right now
which is what this guy does is he raises
money like a madman
and it's not like a ridiculous amount i
mean
saying you're raising tens of millions
of dollars i guess for the for the
average show yeah that is a ridiculous
amount but he's got a track record
and he turns him into multi-billion
dollar things but uh
so so kind of tens of millions of
dollars is not that much money
um but if you click that source thing
what
what does that take you to to the sec
okay i found this file on the sec and i
don't really know what this
is but i don't even remember how i came
across it but this is what interested me
it's a q a session of him having written
it out
and he basically lays out the strategy
of his fourth and fifth business
and so what this appears to be is a q a
that he prepared
and they showed this to a ton of
potential investors
a ton of potential banks and they decide
to invest in him and i think
this was before the company even started
is that what that is
so you're saying this is what he raised
on like there's no deck there's nothing
it's just this is the thing he goes out
and he says
read this document and you can invest
i'm not entirely sure but i think that
is part of it
it's called this is called a schedule
14a which i
i'm not an expert in the sec i believe
that is something that you have to
answer
before a board of directors at a
publicly traded company
um raises money
but i'm not entirely sure but it's
interesting though because he writes in
wonderful
straightforward simple english and you
could read his entire strategy which i'm
going to go through in a second
um but skim that while i bring well i
i'll
summarize the next two businesses that
he did so he started um i told you he
started two oil things but basically
those were oil brokerage businesses then
he started um well waste management
business now his fourth one is called
united rentals
now i don't know if you see this in
canada but if you pay attention to this
now and
if you're listening to this and you live
in america go on a drive in downtown the
downtown city wherever you live
and look at the big box trucks and look
at the rental equipment so look at um
like the caterpillars or the bobcats or
the the um
the construction equipment as well as
the um
porta potties and anything involving
construction or trucking
go and look at those things and i
guarantee you on a lot of them you're
gonna see
united rentals well that is the fourth
company that he started
and he started it with the idea of the
same thing of
waste management he wanted to go out and
he wanted to find a massive industry
that was highly
segmented by small businesses where that
were profitable and great but they
didn't have enough capital to grow
and they were kind of bad at sales and
that's what he did and so he founded it
and in just
five years five years it grew to
4 billion in revenue and 1.2 billion in
ebitda
is he growing via acquisition or is he
just rolling this out and crushing
competition across
the country we're going to talk about
that but what he said was we got there
partly through acquisitions partly
through
organic growth developed by developing
greenfield locations
um he goes we grew by using the same
strategy at
united ways we bought about two thirds
of the branch locations and cold started
another third from scratch i actually
prefer
cold starts is what he said the business
plan for united rentals was to become
the largest equipment rental company in
the world
and leverage our purchasing power
branding and other advantages of size
within 13 months we became number one
leap frogging
fleet frogging hertz which had become
the equipment rental which was the
number one equipment rental business in
1965.
another thing we did was we went fast uh
we went public fast
we formed the company on labor day
weekend
and we were trading on the new york
stock exchange by december
labor day weekend is in may i think
right
so they started the company in may and
five months is that five six seven
months that seven months later they were
public
merrill lynch said it was the fastest
growing or the fastest ipo they've ever
seen
and i stepped down uh uh and so
he stepped down of united rentals in
2007. this is only
five years after starting and
to start the next company but when he
stepped down united rentals if you look
it up now
i believe their market cap is 25 billion
dollars
so he spent five years on this company
and it's worth 25 billion dollars
crazy so listen to what he did after
this
um after i stepped down i began looking
for my next big
thing i studied tons of industries and i
ended up concentrating on transportation
and logistics it's larger and more
fragmented than the industries i've been
i've previously been involved in
it's a 13 billion dollar um
sorry a 13 trillion dollar industry and
here's what this guy says this guy at
the time
is already multi-billionaire but let me
see if i
um i have he wrote out what he does
which was basically
he basically spends three months he
reads tons of reports and then he calls
a hundred experts in each industry and
he just goes and he sits down with them
and just asks them questions it might as
well be a podcast all that's like
exactly how he learned so he's this
multi-billionaire he's his big shot he's
done all this amazing stuff
and he calls these people and he just
sits down and he listens that's all he
does
it's pretty amazing and he did this and
then he's
in this with his new thing it's called
xpo logist
logistics have you heard of this i have
i have heard of this i think it's a
delivery and logistics company like a
competitor to fedex at least that's my
understanding
well we'll put this in the show notes
but in that document up top
that is the document from where he was
raising money for xpeo logistics and
then plain and it looks like it looks
like it's like supply chain so it's like
getting people things they need that are
critical
on time well in there he um in that
document that i sent to you
he i didn't i i couldn't study the whole
thing but in plain english he explains
kind of what they did
and his reasoning for getting into it
and he just says
well i just studied loads of industries
this one seemed industry
interesting i went and um
interviewed a hundred people who were
experts on it i hired
really good people and we're gonna do x
y and z and that x y and z
is exactly what he's done in his uh
last uh businesses and now i wanna
wrap up by by giving you guys incredibly
detailed
um stats or uh
incredibly detailed strategy on what he
does so his first thing that he does
he looks for huge industries with lots
of fragmentation that are small
and profitable but don't have the
capital to uh to scale
so here's what he says he was in a
nutshell this is how you ramp up a
business
you buy a brokerage or some type of
small business with 30 million
in revenue and you add 30 to 40 bodies
to it and you double revenue in time
i've looked into companies that have
executed this plan but most of them
don't have the capital to sustain it i
try to find those businesses and i bring
all the capital to do it
the second thing that he does is he
hires salespeople so he says
i like to hire hungry talented
salespeople at a low base but
big upside for incentives i fund their
training for a few months and it's not
that hard for the winners to build a
million dollar book after a year or so
um it's a business where you have to
make 99 calls a day
and do one or two deals so you have to
hire people who are
psycho i actually don't know this word
what's this we have to hire people who
are psycho chromatically test high
on the need to win scale and low on the
need to be liked scale
a sales person will have a base of 25
000 or 35
000 but can make many times that amount
through an incentivize
a really good incentive program once you
get the right people in the system and
integrate them on the right i.t
it can be really powerful and finally
speaking of i.t when someone asked him
what was the best
acquisition of all time they ever made
he said they made a powerful
software acquisition with a politically
incorrect name
called rental man and we used that to
integrate all of our rental businesses
we rolled up into that company
we couldn't have made the hundreds of
acquisitions we did without
rental man and that was his best
acquisition of all time
and that my friend is brad
jacobs and i can go on i
i like i both love and and um find these
guys kind of mysterious and i kind of
wonder like
what the thing that's missing in all
this is like what keeps him going
what's his purpose how do you how does
he use his money
and and like why does he do this right
what's the driving force
i researched him and the guy looks like
a
wall street stiff did you look up what
he looks like yeah he looks kind of like
um
there's like a character actor that he
looks like i'll try and find a photo
of him like a generic nerdy
like steve ballmer looking kind of guy
yeah he looks like he would be
like in biden or trump's cabinet uh
yeah yeah but i've actually seen
interviews with him he's very endearing
and i think that he's not actually just
a stiff
like wall street like just milk all the
numbers out
i actually think that he um just this is
his bill this is his urge he just loves
to build
and and and he constantly talks about
integrity he goes the common denominator
of everything we buy is the people who
we buy from
have to have high integrity and also one
of our moats is we take care of the
people
of the businesses who work for the
businesses that we're inheriting
in fact the biggest risk of our plan is
that the people who
we buy companies from they leave and so
we treat them all
really really well and so i don't think
this is actually [__] because when i
got his energy from interviews i
actually believed that he was a good
dude and this is just his art
what do you think though what do you
think he does with his money is that
kind of public does he do any
philanthropy
or or anything because i always find it
so interesting i mean there's two ways
to look at like
doing good in the world it's like okay
you do capitalism right you employ a
whole bunch of people you make an
industry more efficient
you add to global gdp you know good
things happen because he does this
right but on the flip side like what's
driving making more money and maybe it
is just
continually maniacally going industry by
industry and improving them and
optimizing them
that's his like gift or whatever but um
but the guy i'm going to talk about next
is really interesting because
he basically uses all his money to do
crazy good things right which is really
fascinating i'll talk about him in a
minute
but do you have any sense of what this
guy does like no with his money like
does
he like he's very much jets like i i
don't i cannot figure it out but i will
i can wrap this up by saying there's a
few things that i've learned from this
person
the first is like taking the red pill
which is like
have you heard i i don't know someone
just used that phrase to me their day
and
and i'm picking it up you should be
careful it's uh associated with all
sorts of
not so uh not so positive connotations
oh well i didn't know that what i mean
is like i guess his
perspective like when you look at what
this person is capable of doing
you think or when you read what he's
done if you didn't know it was true you
would say well that's impossible no one
can do that
but the person has done it repeatedly
over and over and over again
and he seems pretty nonchalant about
that and so my
what i'm learning from him is that um
you can create these amazing things
and it's hard but maybe could be kind of
simple
well it's so inspiring right you
basically go find an industry that has
let's look at the restaurant and
industry in general right restaurants
are disorganized they're very difficult
businesses they're very low margin
people have done this essentially in
restaurants by building fast food chains
right so you go in you build systems you
do training you incentivize people the
right way
and you can make a lot of money doing
that but you can't make a lot of money
usually in an individual restaurant so
what he's done is he's gone out and fun
he finds these fragmented
disorganized industries like you know
waste management or logistics
and he goes okay i'm gonna do the fast
food chain
uh except for that industry it's yeah
and
and it's really really cool um the
second thing that that i learned is he
actually does the same thing as you well
i actually don't know your numbers but i
bet you
they're similar he likes to buy
companies between five and ten times
earnings
um and that's like his number um that's
what i mean
yeah i'd say i love to buy businesses
for that um
that valuation or whatever um but the
problem the problem with buying a
business at that valuation is like
you're buying kind of a crappy business
often if it's going to be that low
well these are trash what he's doing
yeah exactly what he's doing is kind of
building a platform where he's like i
just need one
so i can build the systems and then i
can go and acquire a whole bunch more
and the final thing and then we can move
on is
the guy loves debt and oftentimes that
ends bad
but i personally have zero debt in my
life and i've never really had debt
and i actually think though that not
having debt or not having some type of
leverage
is silly and i've read articles about
him and he talks about it very
unemotionally like he seems like a
really charismatic emotional guy
but he's like yeah look like this makes
total sense because i can grow this
business at 30 percent
uh therefore the cost if i look at the
cost of capital i should allocate
capital this and it just makes sense and
i hear that i'm like yeah everything
you're saying makes total sense i'm just
so fearful and it's really cool that you
don't seem to have that fear
and i think that's interesting yeah and
i think debt
that's it goes back to like not having
fatal potential potential blow-ups in
your life right so
i've heard everything from like you know
i was talking to a guy and he was saying
i'm
super rich guy and he goes i've paid off
my house in full
i never have a mortgage or whatever and
it just gives him that sense of security
maybe this guy has he's so rich he's
already made a whole bunch of money on
other stuff that
he can take a little more risk or he
knows how to structure debt or whatever
it is
um you hear both things and the problem
is you only hear the stories about the
guys who levered up and did really well
there may be a whole bunch of other brad
jacob types
who went out levered up and it totally
[__] them they hit a speed bump oh
yeah lost all that money
so the interesting thing about this
though um
the and the difference between what we
do in this guy is this guy's essentially
starting a new business
um and what we like to do is find a
business that's already working
where we can actually just leave it and
make it you know maybe we'll help plug
in a new
ceo or something like that but we're
actually not messing with it we're not
changing the dna this guy's like
modifying the dna he's doing like crispr
on these businesses
he's working and warping them and
turning that he's working really hard
right so
i don't like to work hard i get really
excited when i hear about people like
this
i'm so glad they exist but i'm like oh
my god this is a big lift i don't want
to do it it's a big lift
but it does seem cool it's cool uh it's
this is like cornrows or sleeve tattoos
i think they're cool
i just don't want it they're cool for
certain people and it works great for
them
exactly tattoos not for me
too it's pretty sick that someone else
has it but i don't know if i want it
totally totally um and i i i think again
going back to like
this guy does make the world better
because he employs a lot of people
in industries where you know people
aren't getting laid off
because of this guy right because he's
managed this business better
he can probably pay people better give
them more opportunity
he's not going to lay them off because
he's got this global business
so it's very it's very positive but what
i would want to understand is what's the
guy do with the money
what's driving him like is he like a sad
empty hole where he's like i have to
keep doing this
all the time or is he like you know
donating it all to charity
or views this as super philanthropic in
and of itself i'm super curious about
that
um i don't know
i i like the only thing that i saw is
that he has a good glass door rating
um which i actually everyone dismisses
glass door
but i'm like yeah there is like i got
made fun of from the michael saylor
podcast
i brought that up i'm like yeah it's not
like facts but it's like there's a
signal that you can learn a little bit
it's the glass door people only go on
glass door when they really hate you
so it's like the voices of the people
who hate you most and if the people who
hate you most
are saying good things or at least okay
things that's a really good sign
right
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back